[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and I decided to make
this quick unexpected video because in
the last two to three days there have
been a lot of news stories appearing
online and talking about a yuria knife
season 2 being confirmed
what's more multiple online sources are
going so far as to claim that a release
date for yuria nights has been set and
that yuria night season 2 is confirmed
for October of this year October 2017
now I wasn't even aware of these
articles floating around online until
snore Li from our discord server gave me
a heads up thank you bro I appreciate it
because here at anime out where we
report anime and manga related news on a
regular basis I have been checking the
official sources for yuria nights the
official Japanese website the official
Japanese Twitter and also
english-language sources like the Anime
News Network and crunchyroll and I could
not find anything on this season 2 being
confirmed stuff so that made me very
confused and I decided to do some
research and to dig into it now I was
going to wait to talk about this in our
weekly Anime News video but when I saw
just how many articles how many multiple
sources are reporting this stuff and how
clickbait t-there titles were I decided
I had to talk about it as soon as
possible to give everyone a heads up
what's going on so that you are not
fooled by these articles just take a
look here and see how many different
media sources are reporting these
stories look at the titles EURion eyes
season 2 new season 2 premiere this
October 2017 jury and I see the two
release date to happen on October 2017
you realized season 2 release date next
level to happen October 2017 and look at
this one by droid report over at the
bottom
yuria nice season to air date confirmed
plot revealed so you can see how
inflammatory these titles and these
claims are however none of these
articles look legitimate to me if you
actually click on them and read through
them most of them for their source site
a bunch of urea nice
fan pages where rumors are talking about
a urea night season to being confirmed
for October there is no legitimate
sources no legitimate news sources that
are reporting this just listen to a
section from one of these articles and
remember these are supposed to be
English language websites this is not me
using google translator a few hours ago
it was reported in numerous fan page
that unionize
season 2 is going to happen you you
Knights held a surprise fans days and it
was visible that those fans were stunned
there were multiple cosplayers who
attended the said event and at the same
time various questions were asked
towards the organizers there is no
mention of what event this was there is
no mention of actual sources or quotes
from who said what it's just completely
general and grammatically incorrect
nonsense let's read on release date this
will not be the first time that this was
asked by fans currently the creator of
the show mr. Okubo is still tight-lipped
about its release date however a member
of the creative team stated that season
two of you tonight is almost here as
noted before mr. Okubo stated in an
interview that you realized is currently
on production
if the hints that were provided is
actually true unionized season two will
be released in October this year so
again we move from general statement
saying that the creators are
tight-lipped to confirmed October this
year so yeah guys I would not give too
much credibility to these sources one of
these sources called Inquisitor com that
is reporting that a EURion I season 2
has been confirmed also has an article
out saying that a seven deadly sins
season 3 has been confirmed and since we
know that seven deadly sins doesn't even
have a season two yet we can say that
these guys got a little bit ahead of
themselves I think a little bit so yeah
guys I just want to give everyone a
quick heads-up so you don't get fooled
in the coming days sometimes where
there's smoke there's fire
and sometimes rumors turn out to be true
but when you're getting them only from
sources like these and not from any
official sources
would be very skeptical at any rate here
at anime Opera we're going to keep
watching on a daily basis for all the
latest news for EURion eyes and a bunch
of other anime so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell and we
will keep you posted also let me know
what you think about these clique baby
news sources and these fake stories down
in the comments I'd love to hear from
you thanks again to my voice Norley for
giving me a heads up about this
information and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]